So that you,
you touched on this idea of the destruction of the work of art.
You know,
and one of the things I really liked about reading Nietzsche,
it was his discussion of into mall,
right,
of resentment.
And,
and it seems to me that a tremendous amount of the motive power that drives the
postmodernist,
let's call it,
it's not a revolution.
Um,
transformation seems to me to be driven by resentment about virtually anything
that has any,
well,
what would you say?
Any merit of competence or aesthetic quality?
And I don't know if that's,
it seems to me that that's partly rooted in the academics disdain for the
business world,
which I think is driven by their relative economic inequality.
Because most people who are as intelligent as academics are from a pure Iq point
of view,
make more money in the private sphere.
And so I think that drives some of it,
but there also seems to be this,
there's a destruction and aim for destruction of the,
of the aesthetic quality of the,
of the literary or artistic work.
It's reduction to nothing but some kind of power game.
And then surrounding that,
the reduction of everything to something that approximates a power gate,
which,
which I can't help but identifying with,
with jealousy and resentment as a,
as a fundamental motivator.
Does that seem reasonable to you?
These professors?
Okay.
Who allege that art is nothing.
But an ideological movement by one elite.
Okay.
Against the,
I guess another group,
right?
These people are Philistines the Philistines,
they're middlebrow hopelessly middlebrow.
Okay.
They,
they,
they have no sense of beauty.
They have no sense of the aesthetic.
Now,
Marxism doesn't deed a search this,
okay.
[inaudible] and tries to reconfigure the universe in terms of materialism,
it seems to it,
and it does not recognize any kind of spiritual dimension.
Now,
I'm an atheist,
but I see the great world religions as enormous works of art as the,
as the,
as the best way to understand the universe and man's place in it.
Okay.
I find them enormously moving that they're there.
They're like enormous Paul.
Unless I had them,
I would,
I have called for the true revolution.
Okay.
What have been okay to make the core curriculum of world education the world?
The great religions of the world.
I feel that is the only way to achieve an understanding.
And it's also a way to,
to,
um,
to present the aesthetic.
Okay.
Because I feel that that the,
that the real sixties' vision was about Xcel,
Taishan elevation,
cosmic consciousness,
all of these things,
they were rejected.
Okay.
By these,
by these midgets.
Okay.
Intellectual midgets who seized onto la car dairy and fuck off.
Right.
It's an eye,
my career has been in the art school,
so I Ma Ma my entire career beginning of Bennington college.
Uh,
so I,
I represent a challenge to this from the perspective of art.
Right?
It is an absolute nonsense.
Okay.
As poststructuralism maintains that reality is mediated by language,
by words,
everything that we can know,
including gender,
it's absolutely madness because I,
I'm teaching students whose majors our ceramics.
Okay.
Or dance.
Who are jazz musicians who understand reality in terms of the body is sensory
activation.
So they now to see what happens if something was going on in the art world as
well.
I identify with Andy Warhol and pop art.
Okay.
That was what was going on during my years in college.
Everything about Andy Warhol was like,
wow.
Admiration.
Wow.
What happened immediately after that in the arts?
1970s okay.
Was this collapse into a snide sort of postmodernism?
Also,
this happened in the art world and it was an utter misunderstanding of culture.
It seems to mean by that movement in the art world that is oppositional art,
in my view,
is dead.
Okay.
It's been and what postmodernism is,
isn't it?
A pathetic attempt to continue.
The old hero is some of the Avalon garb.
The avant garde was genuinely heroic from the early 19th century.
Okay.
Wait,
we're talking about,
you know,
when the core bay,
the realist,
you know,
we're talking about Monet and the impressions,
people who genuinely suffered for the radical ideas and new innovations and so
on,
going right down to,
to to Picasso and down to a,
to Jackson Pollock who like was w who truly suffer it.
Okay.
For him,
for his art,
it was only after his death.
Okay.
That suddenly the market was created for abstract art.
Pop Art killed the avant garde.
The idea that the avant garde continues.
It's an absolute delusion of the contemporary art world,
which feels that it must attack attack,
attack,
challenge.
Okay.
The,
the,
the simplistic beliefs of the,
of the Hoi Polloi.
Okay.
Somehow the Arctic,
what?
Excuse me.
Okay.
All right.
From the moment.
Okay.
Andy Warhol went through and embraced the popular media and in brick instead of
having the opposition to it,
the serious artists have had,
that was the end of oppositional art.
Okay.
So we've been going on now for 50 years.
The postmodernism and academia is hand in hand with the stupidity and
infantilism that masquerades as,
you know,
as,
as important art and galleries everywhere.
This incredible,
incredible,
you know,
its mechanism of contemporary art,
of pushing things that are,
that are so hopelessly derivative that [inaudible] with this idea that once
again,
that the art world sometimes is a superior view of reality.